i realized that we were just 60 of of
america was just kind of tuned out you
know never even knew anything about the
russia hoax and what i call it is the
funnel effect so it's when you take that
95
you feed it through a funnel which you
know ultimately becomes these phones
right here right that are going through
you know youtube facebook instagram talk
etc
and then the left is deciding
what people are able to see especially
those people that are most important
like conservatives you know people that
always vote i mean they're going to know
the difference but it's those people who
really only they only vote in general
elections they don't pay attention a
whole hell of a lot um but you know
they'd want to do their civic duty and i
mean we sat there for you know year
after year pounding away it was clear
the only people that had anything to do
with putin in russia or hillary clinton
and the democrats and adam shift the
democrats on the committee i mean it was
plain day direct evidence that like this
wasn't complicated
so you are running true social
it's obviously president trump's
platform
i think some people know that the
infrastructure is run by the rumble
cloud for total transparency i am part
owner of rumble because of the deal that
we did with locals and i think we're
we're building some awesome stuff so at
some level we are kind of in business
together although this is the first time
that we've ever spoke except for that
that quick hello we had a couple weeks
ago um so what was was it a very natural
transition for you to say okay here i am
in the swamp it's corrupt as hell
everyone's lying about everything uh
maybe i can help clean things up on the
private side which would be the the
social media side
yeah it's a pretty interesting story
actually so
so i wrote this little pamphlet book
called countdown to socialism in july of
2020
and so remember this is before the
censoring of the hunter biden laptop and
of course every all these people
millions of americans getting booted off
or censored on on the tech tyrant
platforms
well i had actually already quit twitter
because i realized that i was being
shadow banned and it was totally useless
for me to even be on the on the platform
so i was the first uh member of congress
to go to parlor okay so parlor was the
company that ultimately got bezos you
know cut off their their servers and
killed essentially killed the company
but i quickly realized that that i that
i had at parlor i mean finally so think
about i was on twitter from essentially
the very beginning i had a million
followers or something maybe a little
over a million followers well
when
when parlor got shut down dave i had
4.2 million followers on parlor
okay and partly i mean that was like in
a year in one year's time
so
so you know i i knew the censorship that
was going on okay i had also been capped
on instagram i've been like at 100 000
people i liked instagram actually i like
to use it i think it's interesting
people all over the globe are are on it
and we'll get more to instagram later
because i think it's important in terms
of the business aspect of what we have
to do
but
insta but
instagram i've been capped at like 100
000 followers for like three years now
right i mean i don't grow and i used to
use it so
so anyway
um
2020 i write this pamphlet warn
everybody about that this is happening
at the same time i i noticed when oh dan
bongino who who you know um who was who
was also there that night
so i had my little podcast that i was
doing essentially and the reason i
created podcast different than you it
wasn't to it wasn't to make money or
anything it was actually i had to get
away
find a way that that my constituents and
people all over the country could hear
directly from me without being censored
so i used my national email list and
database and all of everything that i
had through my campaign side and i was
able to network created this little
podcast
and bongino calls me like man you're
really doing well in this podcast it's
crazy because like i'm even getting like
that i probably never beat you but like
i would be in the top 20 sometimes you
know when i first started it
and uh
and anyway
uh he tells me
hey man you got to go to youtube i'm
like oh okay
[ __ ] i didn't know anything about you
know youtube so i heard i knew about it
i had like a little account there but i
never really thought about doing video
so i did uh so we started doing uh doing
a simulcast right so i'd put it on the
audio side
and then i'd also put it up on on
youtube and what happened was incredible
my my audio just kept going up up up up
my video like shot up immediately
and then like if it could have had
negative views it would have had
negative views like it it flatlined okay
and i said this is impossible this this
can't be possible so
i told my team i said let's just find
let's find a freaking video player
because clearly people there's no way
i'm sending this out to a million people
and people aren't at least like i have
enough family members that would at
least feel sorry for me and at least
click on it to give me a view you know
and of course it didn't make sense
either because the audio listens were
going up right it's in the heart of the
election time i mean it's all about
russia hoax ukraine hoax impeachment
hoaxes i mean all that stuff is hot
people want to hear about it um and i
was you know i had really good guests on
on on the show
and so i just said
and we've we came across this rumble
player
and it's a it's a great story because so
i had 9 000 followers on youtube i
thought ah must be okay i don't know how
many people are on youtube it sounds
okay to me
um didn't know any better so i call up
rumble and chris
first chris from rumbled owner the ceo
of rumble he said he at first he thought
he was under investigation
by the congress
and then he quickly went into because i
just asked him this question i was like
look man i just want you i just want a
place i can park my video and if i put
in
devin nunes podcast right that's that
was the name of it not very creative but
that was it
and i said will it come up and chris was
like well yeah of course like why are
you that seems kind of dumb i said well
go try it right now on youtube
and that was like a moment for for chris
it was like oh my god you couldn't find
it like he couldn't find the podcast
like he didn't believe it existed and
then i had to send him the link so he
could eventually find that yeah there
was a channel and there was a link
so
um long story short
i get up on um on rumble and so like i
said 9 000 followers on youtube
in three weeks so so no one knows of
rumble in the united states of america
no one this is like pre-bondino pre
anybody who went to rumble
i had 35 000 followers in three weeks
and in three months i had almost 400 000
and now you know i'm sitting here today
at a million and i don't really you know
now i'm just kind of posting news clips
on it but
but that shows you right there i mean
those are real numbers right i gave you
the parlor numbers i gave you the rumble
number numbers
so
and in the book that i wrote i
essentially warned the you know people
about that there was a funnel effect
that was taking place it wasn't so much
that 95 of the news media is is fake and
slanted
because because i can handle the 95 5
because i think we have a lot of good
places you know between the podcasters
like yourself and and all the different
news companies the investigative
reporters that we have you know we we
can hold our own 95 to 5.
but we can't but the difference between
between what you know what you know 10
years ago and today and i and i learned
this through the russia hoax and how
people's perceptions were and what
people were learning
is i i realized that we were just 60 of
of america was just kind of tuned out
you know never even knew anything about
the russia hoax and what i call it is
the funnel effect so it's when you take
that
95
you feed it through a funnel which you
know ultimately becomes these phones
right here right that are going through
you know youtube facebook instagram talk
etc
and then the left is deciding
what people are able to see especially
those people that are most important
like conservatives you know people that
always vote i mean they're going to know
the difference but it's those people who
really only they only vote in general
elections they don't pay attention a
whole hell of a lot um but you know
they'd want to do their civic duty and i
mean we sat there for you know year
after year pounding away it was clear
the only people that had anything to do
with putin in russia or hillary clinton
and the democrats and adam schiff and
democrats on the committee i mean it was
plain day direct evidence that like this
wasn't complicated right
but yet nobody knew it and you still you
know you still had even by election 2020
you still had over half of americans
thought that the republicans
had and trump had something to do with
russia so i there was just
it was just a big problem and i knew
that until that funnel
that funnel that the the left controls
which is why they're so ticked off about
elon musk buying twitter until you until
you get rid of that funnel we're going
to continue to have this problem like
the problems we discussed in california
and the problems we see in washington dc
that's kind of
the short story of it all if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here
and to get notified of all future videos
be sure to subscribe and click the
notification bell